Salut, moi c'est Guillaume Hachez. Vous écoutez « 70 minutes avec ». On est reparti pour une nouvelle saison de « 70 minutes avec ».
Vous l'avez peut-être vu sur les réseaux sociaux, je me suis gentiment disloqué l'épaule en juin dernier. Raison pour laquelle il n'y a pas eu de nouveaux épisodes depuis.
D'une part parce que je n'étais pas en état et d'autre part parce que c'est toujours mission impossible de booker des invités pendant l'été, vu que tout le monde prend congé à ce moment-là.
Mais à présent, tout va bien, je suis remis, j'ai bien récupéré en termes de flexibilité et du coup, on peut entamer cette troisième saison en grande pompe.
Un grand merci à Julien Brasseur et Myriam Leroy d'avoir mis sur mon radar ce sujet et mes deux invitées d'aujourd'hui.
Je dois vous avouer qu'au début, j'étais assez intimidé. Je savais pas trop par quel angle aborder le sujet qui me semblait hyper délicat.
Mais plus je me suis documenté, plus j'ai compris que j'avais là un sujet en or et un combo parfait d'intervenantes pour en discuter dans le podcast.
Aujourd'hui, je passe 70 minutes avec Florence Hainaut et Marie Peltier. C'est parti. Bonjour à tous, ravi de vous retrouver pour une nouvelle saison de « 70 minutes avec ».
Après une deuxième saison qui fut assez agitée pour cause de confinement,
on démarre aujourd'hui en force avec un sujet qui n'est pas des moindres, puisque on va parler aujourd'hui de la place que donnent Internet et les réseaux sociaux au débat.
On va parler de bulles idéologiques, de construction de récits, de conspirationnisme et enfin, on aura l'occasion de discuter d'un concept qui est sur toutes les lèvres, à savoir la fameuse
Cancel Culture, qu'on peut également prononcer à la bruxelloise en Cancel Culture.
Existe-t-elle vraiment ? Est-ce qu'on peut encore tout dire ? Qui sont ceux qui la dénoncent ? Tant de questions qui vont nous intéresser aujourd'hui.
Et pour ce faire, j'ai le plaisir d'être accompagné non pas par une, mais par deux intervenantes de qualité, à commencer par Marie Peltier. Bonjour Marie.
Bonjour.
Marie, tu es professeure d'histoire à la Haute École Galilée et tu te spécialises, entre autres choses, sur les questions de complotisme.
Et tu as notamment sorti il y a deux ans un livre qui s'appelle « Obsession. Dans les coulisses du récit complotiste ».
Je suis également accompagné par l'unique, inénarrable Florence Hainaut. Bonjour Florence.
Bonjour Guillaume. Et comme tu as dit bonjour à tous et pas bonjour à toutes et à tous, je propose de te canceller.
Ça commence bien. Florence, tu es journaliste. Tu as travaillé pendant plus de 10 ans à la RTBF avant de la quitter pour devenir journaliste freelance et continuer en fait à travailler avec la RTBF.
Et tu prépares actuellement un documentaire sur le cyberharcèlement. Est-ce que c'est juste ?
Oui, sur le cyberharcèlement, j'imagine, plus spécifiquement.
Et spécifiquement, je pense aussi, en ce qui concerne les femmes journalistes, si je ne dis pas de bêtises.
Non, en fait, on parle beaucoup du harcèlement des femmes journalistes, mais quand on regarde les chiffres qu'on a à disposition,
les femmes qui prennent la parole sont toutes harcelées dans les mêmes proportions.
Donc le pourcentage de femmes journalistes harcelées sur les réseaux sociaux rejoint le pourcentage mondial de femmes qui ont subi des violences via Internet. Donc...
Tu veux dire que Marie est autant harcelée que toi, c'est ça que tu veux dire ?
Oui, t'as- Aïe, aïe, aïe. C'est ça quoi. Je trouve que dans ton podcast aujourd'hui, il manque Zakia Khattabi, Myriam Leroy et Rokhaya Diallo.
Et là, tu vas voir ce qu'est une shitstorm. Déjà avec nous deux, c'est une shitstorm.
Ouais, une chose à la fois. Mais cela dit, Rokhaya Diallo devrait nous rejoindre dans quelques semaines, sauf imprévu.
Quel excellent imprévu.
Alors, la question de la Cancel Culture, des bulles idéologiques et du fameux, entre guillemets, « On ne peut plus rien dire » qu'on entend partout.
Ouin, ouin.
Cette question, elle est pas-- C'est bien. Si à chaque fois que je dis : « On ne peut plus rien dire », tu fais ouin-ouin, c'est...
Cette question, elle est pas nouvelle. Et c'est d'ailleurs tout l'objet du livre de Marie, « Obsession », qui, on l'a dit, est paru il y a déjà deux ans.
Mais voilà, je dirais que cette question, elle a été particulièrement centrale ces derniers mois, et en ce qui concerne notamment la fameuse affaire Florence Hainaut, entre guillemets.
Créée de toutes pièces hein, parce que il n'y a pas d'affaire.
On va-- oui, je mettais des gros guillemets autour de ça, bien sûr, mais exercice difficile. Florence, est-ce que je peux te demander d'essayer de nous résumer les faits, à ta manière ?
Alors cet été, je commençais à être un petit peu irritée de voir dans les médias des opinions qui allaient toutes dans le même sens sur le port du foulard.
Et comme c'est un sujet que je connais, sur lequel j'ai travaillé,
enfin, qui m'intéresse depuis longtemps et que j'ai travaillé, sur lequel j'ai travaillé pendant plus d'un an dans le cadre d'un master de spécialisation en études de genre, ben j'ai décidé,
d'écrire une carte blanche sur le sujet avec un positionnement qui est sans doute perçu comme progressiste.
Je disais pas des choses vraiment choquantes hein, je
proposais de donner la parole et d'écouter les femmes qui portent le foulard au lieu de parler à leur place et de décider ce qu'elles doivent faire et de donner un sens à leur foulard sans les écouter sur le sujet.
Une position plutôt intersectionnelle et assez proche de-
Alors-
...ce qu'a pu développer dans ce podcast quelqu'un comme Corine Torrekens, je pense.
En fait,
la position en elle-même peut être considérée comme intersectionnelle, mais j'ai fait très attention à ne pas du tout aborder cet angle parce que je sais que le mot intersectionnel rend une série de personnes complètement
folles, mais vraiment folles.
Souvent des gens qui ne comprennent pas le concept. Donc je ne développe absolument pas-
Ça n'est pas arrivé, personne n'est devenu fou. C'est ça que tu veux nous dire.
Tu parles. C'est un angle que je ne développe absolument pas dans ma carte blanche. Mais-
D'accord
...mais est-ce que je crois à l'intersectionnalité ? À mort, évidemment.
Très bien. Donc, tu publies cette carte blanche. Que se passe-t-il ensuite ?
Eh ben, je me fais déchiqueter. Alors, je me doutais que ça allait faire grincer des dents et que les vingt habituels comptes Twitter qui ne m'aiment pas allaient faire ouin-ouin.
Ce que je n'avais pas prévu-
Tu fais très, très bien le ouin-ouin.
Le ouin-ouin ? Bah oui, tu m'étonnes. Ce que j'avais pas prévu, c'est qu'une-
Cette espèce de brol qui se fait appeler Observatoire des fondamentalismes et qui n'observe en fait qu'une religion qu'elle estime fondamentaliste tout le temps, allait m'accuser de proximité avec l'islam radical.
Et donc là, de : « Ouais sa carte blanche chez nous ne nous dit comme rien, elle n'a qu'à retourner à ses casseroles », on est passé de,
on se demandait si j'allais devenir une terroriste et on m'a accusée de soutenir l'islam radical.
Enfin bon, au début, c'est peut-être le dernier truc que je n'avais pas lu sur moi. Donc au début, je t'avoue que ça m'a fait rire.
Je me suis dit : « Ouah super celle-là ! » J'avais pas cette médaille à mon tableau.
et puis ça n'a pas du tout fait rire par contre la Fédération européenne des journalistes qui est un peu plus habituée à gérer les menaces sur les journalistes.
Et eux ont, voilà, eux ont réagi.
Et après ça, je crois que je me suis fait mais insulter, déchiqueter, diffamer, mais pendant des semaines et des semaines entières,
sur des réseaux sociaux sur lesquels je ne suis plus parce que j'ai quitté Twitter il y a trois mois.
Et pendant cet épisode, j'ai quitté Facebook parce que franchement, ça me fatiguait de devoir effacer toutes les heures des commentaires qui disaient que j'avais de la merde dans le cerveau.
Et je comptais quand même profiter un peu de mes vacances, donc je suis partie de Facebook.
Et c'est devenu-- Je pense que quand tu dis « Affaire Florence Hainaut », en fait,
y a des personnes qui ont voulu faire croire que c'était une affaire, que c'était le ballet
gay, de l'affaire Florence Hainaut, mais c'était juste quelqu'un qui a écrit une carte blanche considérée comme progressiste et qui s'est fait complètement déchiqueter après.
Enfin quand je dis déchiqueter, moi, j'en sors sans cicatrice hein, mais je veux dire qui s'est fait insulter pendant des semaines après.
Et ce qui est quand même très intéressant, c'est qu'on a parlé d'absolument tout autour de cette carte blanche, mais personne n'a répondu aux arguments que j'avançais. Personne.
Tu dis : « C'est pas une affaire parce que c'est juste une carte blanche et des gens qui répondent furieusement en t'insultant sur les réseaux sociaux » ?
Si c'est une affaire, en tout cas, c'est pas l'affaire Florence Hainaut. Tu vois ? C'est parce que je-
OK, OK
...en fait en disant l'affaire Florence Hainaut, tu mets le focus sur
qui je suis. Et c'est exactement ce que les gens ont fait, parce que la plupart des gens qui se sont excités sur cette carte blanche n'en avaient strictement rien à foutre de ce que j'écrivais dedans.
Ils cherchent-- enfin ils ont juste trouvé une occasion délicieuse de s'exciter sur ma tronche. Et donc on peut dire que c'est l'affaire de la carte blanche ou l'affaire du foulard ou l'affaire de...
Mais en tout cas pas l'affaire Florence Hainaut.
Parce que donc y a plusieurs éléments qui viennent encore un petit peu complexifier l'affaire. Puisque on a pu voir vraiment, et on aura l'occasion d'en parler, mais
construction de récits autour de cette affaire, beaucoup d'accusations et pas mal d'accusations très fallacieuses.
Un bon gros lot de complotisme dont on aura l'occasion de parler plus tard.
Est-ce que tu savais bien que j'avais le bras absolument longissime ? J'arrive à censurer des médias, j'arrive à manipuler les instances journalistiques européennes et j'influence aussi des partis politiques.
Tout ça, moi, toute seule. Je suis assez fière. Ces gens me prêtent un pouvoir qui me rend forte en fait.
OK, je ferais bien une blague là-dessus, mais je pense qu'il y a des gens qui pensent très sérieusement que tout ça est vrai.
Donc je vais éviter de-
Mais si ça tombe c'est vrai, moi je le saurai jamais.
OK. Mais donc, tu disais : « Tout le monde se crist-- » enfin : « Ces personnes-là se concentraient en particulier sur toi, ton nom, ta personne.
» Et c'était, entre autres choses, le cas de cette personne qui s'appelle également Florence, Florence Bergeaud-Blackler, qui a également publié une carte blanche dans Le Soir pour te répondre et qui était un petit peu le,
le festival au ad hominem et au, ou euh-- Je sais pas comment on dit ad hominem pour une femme.
Ad virginem, je ne sais pas.
Non, t'inquiète pas, je vais pas te... Je vais pas t'obliger à tout féminiser. Sinon, je te réponds pas. Oui, la première version qui a été publiée dans Le Soir était vraiment insultante.
Elle parlait de mon argumentation trouée, de-- Je sais plus les mots qu'elle utilisait, au consommateur de ma bêtise, etc.
Alors moi, je veux bien qu'on réponde à ce que je dis, mais on n'attaque pas. Enfin, je veux dire, c'est pas une manière de faire les choses.
Enfin, on n'attaque pas les gens en disant : « Je vous réponds pas parce que vous êtes stupide. » Ça n'a pas de sens quoi.
Je veux dire, c'est-- Enfin, que les gens fassent ça sur Twitter, c'est déjà assez choquant, mais que ça paraisse dans des médias traditionnels, on--
Je n'ai pas très bien compris pourquoi Le Soir a publié cette première version et je m'en suis émue auprès du rédacteur en chef.
En disant : « Je comprends pas. » Il m'a dit : « Oui, en effet. » Enfin, et donc elle a été dépubliée, expurgée de certaines des attaques et republiée.
Et c'était donc bien là la preuve que mon bras longissime avait réussi à censurer Le Soir.
Ouais, ouais, ouais. Donc oui, donc sur base de ça, on t'a accusée de censure pour le coup. Et que se passe-t-il ensuite à partir de là ?
Je sais pas, une espèce de mouvement perpétuel. Les gens se nourrissent de n'importe quoi, se nourrissent des accusations de cet observatoire qui m'accuse d'être proche
des Frères musulmans, de l'islam radical.
Je lis des trucs, enfin, ça continue à me faire un peu rire hein, je suis désolée. Alors que c'est grave comme accusation, mais je trouve ça tellement, tellement énorme.
Que je suis une ennemie de la démocratie. Enfin, ah oui OK.
Moi, on m'a traitée de collabo là depuis plusieurs jours. Je sais pas, on a sûrement dû te le dire aussi que tu étais une collabo, non ?
Ah ben non, ça, j'ai pas encore eu. Comme quoi j'ai peut-être encore une belle carrière à faire sur les réseaux sociaux, même sans y être, parce que collabo, ça, j'ai pas encore eu.
Mais c'est open bar. Allez-y, tweetez sous le podcast, je prends.
Mais donc, tu mentionnais cette accusation de proximité avec l'islamisme radical, les Frères musulmans ou que sais-je.
Donc là, on est en plein dans-- Bon parce qu'on va quand même préciser que c'est faux hein, si jamais-
Oui, oui, mais évidemment, c'est faux.
Si jamais y en a qui ne suivent pas au fond de la classe. Donc on est en plein dans la construction de récits conspirationnistes sur les réseaux sociaux.
Marie, c'est tout le sujet de ton livre. Quelle analyse tu fais de cette affaire ?
Bah je dirais de cette polémique en fait, parce que moi, c'est comme ça que je traite généralement ces histoires-là.
En fait, justement dans le bouquin qui est en fait mon deuxième bouquin, Obsession, j'en ai écrit un premier en 2016 qui s'appelle L'ère du complotisme.
Mais dans le deuxième, donc, dans le dernier que j'ai écrit, j'analyse justement surtout des polémiques qui ont eu lieu en ligne.
Alors, j'analyse surtout des polémiques qui ont eu lieu en France, et qui, en fait, comment dire, viennent tout le temps agréger les mêmes ingrédients, on pourrait dire, les mêmes obsessions, d'où le titre du livre.
Ces obsessions, c'est quoi ? C'est généralement le féminisme, c'est généralement l'islam et le voile islamique, c'est généralement l'imaginaire du complot, avec la défiance envers les médias, etc.
Et c'est vrai que c'est intéressant dans cette histoire récente en Belgique, c'est que ça vient reprendre tous ces ingrédients-là
qu'on avait déjà vus, par exemple, dans une polémique que je peux citer parce que celle-là, elle est célèbre et je l'analyse dans le bouquin, qui est la polémique autour de la chanteuse Mennel, par exemple.
Bon, là, c'est encore un autre degré de violence parce qu'on est en France aussi.
Juste pour rappel, il s'agit de la personne qui avait participé à l'émission The Voice France avec-
Un turban, peut-être
...en portant foulard, un turban pour le coup, ouais, ce qui avait, voilà, réveillé pas mal de frustrés, que ce soit à gauche ou à droite, voilà, au nom de, voilà, une défense de la laïcité à la française, etc.
Oui, ce qui est marrant, c'est que moi, j'ai vu cette émission en direct. Je me souviens, on l'a entendu chanter et je me suis retournée, j'ai dit à mon mec, j'ai dit : « Ça passera jamais.
Elle est en foulard, ça ne va pas passer ». Parce que c'est toujours le même schéma. Quand des femmes qui portent le foulard
s'expriment sur autre chose que sur leur foulard, c'est-à-dire quand elles font partie d'un syndicat
étudiant, elles sont blogueuses beauté.
Y a eu aussi un cas au Royaume-Uni. Ou quand elles sont chanteuses. En fait, on leur refuse de s'exprimer sur autre chose que leur foulard.
Et pour le coup, là, elles sont cancellées. Parce que ces gonzesses, on les fait disparaître. Elle a dû partir de l'émission The Voice qu'elle rêvait de faire.
La blogueuse beauté en Angleterre qui avait eu un contrat avec L'Oréal, y a eu une telle polémique parce qu'elle portait le foulard, ben elle a perdu le contrat.
Alors si ça, c'est pas de la cancel culture, c'est quoi d'autre quoi ?
Bah en fait, c'est ça. Et c'est en ça qu'il faut remettre pour comprendre toutes ces questions, il faut remettre en perspective les rapports de domination en fait.
Et c'est là que y a énormément de confusion et que y a des acteurs dans le débat public actuellement qui procèdent vraiment à de l'inversion des réalités permanentes.
C'est qu'effectivement, les personnes qui sont vraiment... 'fin, je vais pas utiliser le mot canceller parce que je critique ce concept, donc je vais pas le reprendre en compte, mais qui
subissent vraiment, on va dire, le poids du débat public, c'est-à-dire qu'ils le subissent
réellement dans leur vie, ce sont des personnes qui généralement font partie d'une minorité.
Donc, en l'occurrence, bah dans le cas de Mennel, elle était, c'était une femme évidemment, musulmane portant le foulard.
En plus, on avait retrouvé, c'était un peu le prétexte, mais on avait retrouvé des anciens statuts Facebook qu'elle avait faits qui étaient complotistes.
Et donc, on l'accusait aussi de toutes sortes de choses au nom de ses-
Quand elle avait 14 ans ou 15 ans quoi.
Oui, c'est ça. Et qui sont des choses, enfin moi, je le sais pour travailler avec des jeunes, qui sont malheureusement des propos extrêmement répandus quoi hein.
Donc, qui n'avaient en fait pas grand-chose à voir avec son foulard. Donc y a eu tout un gros amalgame autour du...
Comme si parce qu'elle portait le foulard, elle était complotiste, etc. Enfin, les gens mélangent tout. Et en fait, effectivement, ces personnes payent un prix très très fort de vouloir s'exprimer dans le débat public.
Or, en plus, Mennel, c'était même pas vouloir vraiment s'exprimer dans le débat public. C'était, comme tu le disais, Florence, c'était vouloir chanter, tout simplement.
Elle voulait chanter.
C'était être autre chose qu'une femme qui porte le foulard.
Exactement.
N'être pas que ça, quoi.
C'est ça. Et en plus, bon, je pense que ce qui les a rendus dingues dans le cas de Mennel, 'fin, c'est une petite parenthèse, mais c'est pas seulement une parenthèse parce que je pense que ça dit beaucoup,
c'est qu'elle était jolie, elle chantait très bien et que voilà, y avait...
Je veux dire, si elle avait pas correspondu à certains critères et de beauté et de-
De talent.
...de talent, voilà, je pense que ça aurait moins fait bugger toute une série de personnes. 'Fin, c'est horrible à dire hein, mais le sexisme, ça fonctionne comme ça. Et je pense que,
'fin, on est bien placées pour le savoir hein. Si t'es considérée aux yeux de la société comme pas trop moche, pas trop conne et en plus que tu l'ouvres,
ben tu as vraiment un rapport de domination qui s'oppose à toi en permanence quoi.
Et effectivement, moi, ce qui m'inquiète en fait, c'est que jusqu'ici en Belgique, honnêtement, parce que moi, j'ai surtout travaillé sur la France hein, ces dernières années.
Honnêtement, jusqu'ici en Belgique, on était plutôt calmes, comparativement à la France.
Mais ça, c'était avant.
Oui, ça, c'était avant. Et parce que là, ces derniers mois, et moi, je le vois aussi à titre personnel, c'est que moi, jusqu'à y a un an ou deux, j'avais jamais été attaquée par la tutosphère belge, à peu près.
C'est-à-dire qu'ils disaient : « Ouais, Marie Peltier, elle s'occupe de ces trucs de Syrie, de complotisme. » Je sais pas, ils me foutaient la paix quoi.
Et pourtant, Dieu sait que j'ai été attaquée beaucoup en France hein, par des mouvances comme le Printemps républicain, etc. 'Fin, j'ai-
C'est toujours un plaisir, ça.
Oui, c'est ça. Et des gens qui ont été très très violents avec moi. Je pourrais raconter beaucoup de choses, mais c'est pas le sujet.
Mais ce qui est marrant, c'est que maintenant, je vois vraiment un basculement. Limite, les Français me foutent un peu la paix.
Et par contre, en Belgique, c'est devenu, mais c'est devenu totalement délirant en fait. C'est-à-dire qu'on a l'alliance en fait à la fois,
de forces d'extrême droite, c'est-à-dire vraiment l'extrême droite islamophobe, raciste, etc.
Avec des gens qui ne viennent pas de l'extrême droite, mais qui veulent justement faire valoir un rapport de domination par rapport aux femmes, par rapport aux musulmans, etc.
Et donc on a une espèce d'agglomérat comme ça, de différentes tendances politiques qui s'entendent en fait très bien pour s'en prendre aux femmes, pour s'en prendre aux racisés, pour s'en prendre à, bah à différentes minorités quoi.
En faisant croire en plus que ce sont eux les victimes et nous les harceleurs quoi.
Oui, ça, j'adore.
Mais c'est intéressant que tu dises la twittosphère parce que le réseau social où les femmes sont les plus violentées, c'est Twitter et c'est aussi le réseau social le plus masculin avec 66 % d'utilisateurs hommes.
Et la violence contre les femmes est tellement institutionnalisée sur Twitter que,
en 2017 et en 2018,
Amnesty International, qui est quand même une organisation qu'on connaît généralement parce qu'ils défendent des prisonniers politiques en grève de la faim,
eh ben s'est penchée sur la question de la violence,
à l'encontre des femmes sur Twitter dans une campagne qui s'appelle Toxic Twitter et en fait où ils défendent l'idée que les droits des femmes, les droits humains des femmes ne sont pas respectés sur Twitter.
Et eux, leur angle, c'est d'interpeller Twitter en disant : « Qu'est-ce que vous mettez en place pour changer ça ?
» Et tous les chiffres sont accablants quoi. Et les femmes quittent Twitter. On ne sait pas-
Et moi, je vais d'ailleurs le dire, c'est l'occasion. Moi, j'ai décidé de quitter Twitter aussi hein, donc-
Oh, tu vas voir, c'est génial.
Déjà ma vie
était vraiment meilleure depuis que j'ai quitté Facebook parce que je déteste Facebook pour,
pour d'autres raisons, parce qu'effectivement, la violence ne s'y exprime pas exactement de la même manière, mais je trouve que Facebook, c'est un lieu très pervers aussi,
parce que Facebook, c'est un lieu où tout le monde parle sur le dos de tout le monde et je trouve que ça alimente beaucoup des dynamiques malsaines dans le débat public.
Mais Twitter, effectivement, c'est par ailleurs un lieu que j'ai beaucoup aimé,
sur un plan politique. D'ailleurs, ben pour ceux qui ont lu mon livre Obsession, pour ceux qui vont le lire, ils le verront, c'est mon champ d'observation principal.
C'est Twitter, c'est un laboratoire politique assez extraordinaire à observer. Donc moi, j'ai toujours adoré, enfin, j'avoue hein, j'ai adoré ce lieu en termes de champ d'observation.
Et puis aussi, j'ai adoré prendre part au débat parce que y a un côté très ludique à Twitter, etc. Je pense qu'on peut tous trouver.
Mais en même temps, c'est ce que tu dis, Florence, et je suis tout à fait d'accord, c'est que structurellement, c'est un lieu, mais d'une violence, mais inouïe, en fait, pour les femmes.
Et je pense vraiment que même les hommes qui nous soutiennent, entre guillemets, ne mesurent pas ce que c'est qu'avoir d'abord être une femme et avoir une parole publique actuellement, donc en 2020,
avec le retour des forces réactionnaires et machistes, voilà, mais particulièrement sur Twitter.
C'est-à-dire que s'exprimer publiquement sur Twitter, en plus sur des questions politiques, moi, je le sais hein, parce que par exemple, je m'exprime beaucoup sur la Syrie.
Bah une femme qui l'ouvre sur un sujet qui est censé être un sujet de mec, franchement, ça déchaîne un truc, mais complètement sidérant. Et c'est pas-
J'ai mis longtemps à comprendre ça. Enfin, maintenant, je le comprends et c'est devenu un terrain de recherche.
C'est le sujet du documentaire que je prépare avec Myriam Leroy. Mais quand ça m'est tombé sur le coin de la tronche en 2016, quand j'ai commencé à présenter l'émission politique dominicale de la RTBF, Les Décodeurs,
je me suis pris mais un flot, mais continu d'insultes,
extrêmement, extrêmement misogynes.
Et au début, j'ai pas du tout compris ce qui se passait. Pourtant, j'avais toutes les clés pour comprendre parce que les gens me disaient, les gens disaient que,
que j'avais sucé pour réussir, que j'étais grosse, que j'étais moche, que j'étais une greluche, que je ferais bien d'être chroniqueuse pour Touche pas à mon poste, que--
les gens disaient, y a des gens qui écrivaient carrément : « Il faut remettre cette greluche à sa place.
» Alors, ils m'avaient vraiment donné toutes les clés pour analyser le discours,
mais quand on se prend un flot et surtout quand c'est le début du flot de haine, on comprend pas exactement dans quoi on se trouve
et on est très isolé.
Moi, j'étais très isolée parce que les réactions autour de moi, de mes collègues, de mes consœurs, de mes confrères, de ma hiérarchie, 'fin, c'était de dire : « C'est le revers de la médaille, faut pas nourrir le troll.
Ah ben, c'est comme ça, t'es fort,
t'es quand même fort exposée. » Et donc j'ai vraiment mis des années à comprendre ce qui s'était passé à ce moment-là, parce que la première réaction, c'est de se dire : « Mon Dieu, mais
je déclenche tellement de haine, c'est qu'il doit y avoir un problème avec moi.
» Et en fait, quand je repose mon regard d'aujourd'hui sur cette période, je me dis : « Mais allez, mais c'était limpide quoi. »
Les gens, ils me disaient : « Mignonnette, 'fin, retourne à tes casseroles, ne mets pas les pieds en politique, ça n'est pas un domaine pour toi, c'est pas un domaine pour les femmes.
» Et à l'époque, voilà, j'ai vraiment mis du temps à comprendre ce qui s'était passé. Et le fait de comprendre, de théoriser et de travailler sur le sujet, ça aide à ce qu'en fait-
Ça t'atteint moins, du coup quoi.
Ah complètement, parce qu'en fait, c'est pas vraiment moi qu'ils insultent.
Bien sûr.
C'est ce que je réveille en eux et ça, je suis chaton, 'fin, je suis pas votre psy quoi. 'Fin, je veux dire, soyez-
Oui, mais c'est tout à fait ça. Et c'est pour ça que c'est très important, 'fin, et humblement, c'est un peu ce que j'ai essayé de faire ces dernières années, c'est de politiser ces questions, en fait hein.
C'est en fait tout le temps les mêmes cibles, effectivement, 'fin le même type de cible, le même type de profil, qui sont attaqués.
Et effectivement, y a en fait un truc que moi, maintenant, j'appelle la politisation des affects. C'est-à-dire qu'en fait,
ce sont des personnes et c'est pas forcément la caricature du troll caché derrière son ordinateur qui est un pauvre gars qui a-
Ah non, non, non, non. Moi, je me fais insulter par des gens sous leur vrai nom hein. Un certain Jean Guffens qui me traite de salope, de saloperie, de garce.
Il le fait sous son vrai nom hein. J'ai été portée plainte d'ailleurs.
Ah oui, oui. Mais moi, j'aurais des tas d'exemples aussi. Puis des gens qui
aussi, par exemple, qui travaillent sur la Syrie comme moi, mais qui sont jaloux à crever du fait que ça marche un peu pour moi et donc qui font des faux comptes pour essayer de m'attaquer, de me discréditer, etc.
'Fin, des trucs complètement ridicules.
Oui, mais les gens, adoptez un chien quoi, faites quelque chose.
Mais c'est ça. Donc en fait, je pense que, 'fin franchement, ça va peut-être te faire rigoler, mais je le dis très sérieusement et je suis en train d'écrire là-dessus d'ailleurs.
Y a vraiment un problème aussi de prise en compte des problématiques de santé mentale, vraiment.
C'est-à-dire que je pense vraiment qu'on a beaucoup de retard là-dessus, c'est que les réseaux sociaux viennent réveiller des problèmes psychologiques et/ou psychiatriques chez pas mal de personnes.
Ces problèmes psychologiques prennent une
coloration politique à la faveur justement de toutes ces polémiques. Et donc les gens viennent chercher des logiciels politiques pour en fait essayer d'expliquer leur sentiment de frustration, leur jalousie-
Alors qu'il suffirait d'aller faire un petit stage à la Ramée, hein.
Exactement. Non, et une bonne thérapie quoi, on y est tous passés hein, à un moment donné, ça fait du bien.
Et vraiment, je pense qu'il y a de ça et que la confusion actuelle, parce qu'on voit qu'on est dans une extrême confusion, on ne sait plus très bien qui est harcelé, qui est harceleur, etc., parce que ces gens nourrissent beaucoup la confusion.
Elle est en partie liée à cette confusion entre problématique de santé mentale, problématique politique, obsessions qui ne sont pas réglées et le format, comme on vient d'en parler, le format propre à Twitter qui exacerbe tout ça.
Et donc on fait le merdier quoi.
Et donc tu évoquais la politisation des affects. Tu évoquais sur Twitter hier le fait que souvent, quand tu te plains de ce que tu dois traverser sur les réseaux sociaux, on vient te soutenir de manière très-
Affective.
...oui, très affective, voilà, on t'envoie des petits cœurs, on t'envoie des soutiens, etc.
Alors que j'en ai clairement ras-le-
Alors que oui. Donc, alors que c'est pas ce que tu demandes. Toi, tu demandes plutôt un soutien politisé, un soutien des institutions, un soutien systémique.
Oui, c'est-à-dire qu'en fait, je remarque de plus en plus, et moi, c'est pour ça que je vais quitter aussi ce réseau et même de manière générale, les réseaux sociaux, c'est que, comment dire ?
Y a à la fois donc une politisation des affects, comme je disais, donc une tendance à mettre des logiciels idéologiques sur nos sentiments et en même temps, bizarrement, à,
comment dire, à dépolitiser assez profondément la parole de certains et de certaines.
Et en l'occurrence, ma parole à moi, je sens souvent qu'elle est dépolitisée. C'est-à-dire que parfois, donc je parle,
par exemple, de harcèlement que je subis, mais pour moi, j'en parle parce que c'est une problématique que j'estime politique, qui concerne tout le monde.
Et j'ai l'impression que pour beaucoup de gens, et je leur jette pas la pierre, hein,
ils me voient comme une espèce d'influenceuse de plus, comme si on était tous des influenceurs et que je me plaignais des haters et que donc il fallait m'envoyer un peu de love pour que je sois un peu mieux quoi.
Et en fait, ils comprennent pas que c'est pas du tout de ça que je parle quoi. C'est qu'en fait, je travaille sur ces questions depuis des années.
Je remarque concrètement, structurellement, qu'il y a un contexte politique qui fait que je ne peux plus faire mon travail, en fait.
Par exemple, je prends l'exemple tout récent parce que j'ai de nouveau eu un épisode de harcèlement totalement ridicule de la part des anti-masques.
Mais moi, très clairement, je m'étais exprimée, par exemple, sur une manifestation anti-masque qui avait eu lieu à Botanique.
Pourquoi je m'étais exprimée là-dessus ? Mais putain, parce que je bosse là-dessus depuis 10 ans, les gars, c'est ma spécialité quoi.
Et donc je suis légitime à m'exprimer là-dessus.
C'est une espèce de manifestation qui a eu lieu ce dimanche, si je dis pas de bêtises, au Botanique et où on retrouvait donc un mouvement anti-masque avec, par exemple, entre autres choses,
des panneaux et des pancartes qui évoquaient QAnon, donc cette,
cette théorie du complot nord-américaine.
Et donc oui, donc quelque chose qui touche directement à ton expertise, oui. Donc tu avais toute la légitimité pour t'exprimer là-dessus.
Et pourtant, voilà, le système bien en place faisait que, on te refusait cette légitimité. On estimait que tu n'étais pas la personne qui devait s'exprimer là-dessus.
C'est ça. Et avec justement une alliance, comme j'évoquais tout à l'heure, une alliance entre les anti-masques. Bon forcément, eux, c'est un peu normal qu'ils me détestent, hein.
Bon voilà, je dis que c'est des gens d'extrême droite et des conspirationnistes et qu'il faut les combattre.
Donc forcément, ils m'aiment pas. Ça, à la rigueur, je trouve que c'est normal dans le débat politique.
Mais le problème, c'est que j'ai vu directement s'allier à ces anti-masques, eh ben les harceleurs, ben les harceleurs de Florence quoi. Enfin...
Tu vois, tu vois, Florence, que-
Ça me fait trop débile.
Tu vois, tu vois, Florence, que cette affaire porte ton nom et que ce sont les harceleurs de Florence.
Ah ben oui, mais y en a que j'ai sur le dos depuis des années et des années. Et donc à un moment, ben j'y suis presque attachée.
Tu sais, ils me manquent, ces gens-là. Je crois que j'ai laissé un vide chez eux quand je me suis barrée.
Mais ce qui est terrible avec, eh ben toi, Marie, au moins, t'as capté quand tu dis : « Les harceleurs de Florence », ce que je trouve vraiment très compliqué avec le harcèlement via les réseaux sociaux.
J'aime bien dire « via » parce que le harcèlement, les réseaux sociaux, c'est le médium.
Bien sûr.
Le harcèlement, il se passe dans la vraie vie. Le terrain, ben voilà, le terrain de combat, c'est ton corps, c'est ton esprit, c'est dur.
C'est pas juste sur les réseaux sociaux. Enfin, c'est... Tu es harcelée de la même manière que
si t'es harcelée par un corbeau qui t'envoie des lettres, on va pas dire que tes boîtes aux lettres harcelaient, tu vois, t'es harcelée, enfin, c'est tout.
Ce qui est assez compliqué, je trouve que le plus compliqué à vivre, c'est l'espèce de double peine.
Comme moi, je traîne dans mon sillage depuis des années entre 10 et 30 débilos, c'est toujours les mêmes, qui foutent le dawa partout où je vais.
C'est-à-dire que si je participe à une conférence, ils vont envoyer plein de tweets, faire des détournements, des vidéos de la conférence, ils vont insulter, etc.
Eh ben, l'image... Aujourd'hui, j'ai une image de fille problématique parce que j'ai dans mon sillage des gens problématiques.
Aujourd'hui, c'est moi la personne problématique. Et donc j'ai réussi à faire ça quand même. Là, on peut reparler de mon bras longissime.
J'ai quand même réussi à faire annuler un événement sur le cyberharcèlement organisé par un ministère parce que j'avais proposé de remplacer l'intervenante qui était malade, de la remplacer au pied levé.
Et elles ont préféré annuler l'événement en disant : « Ouah, bon, Florence Hainaut, bad buzz, etc.
» Et donc oui, ça a des vrais effets dans ma vie et dans ma vie professionnelle. Il y a des portes professionnelles qui se sont fermées parce qu'à un moment, on
Les gens mélangent un peu les problèmes que j'ai et le problème que je pourrais éventuellement représenter. Et donc je suis considérée par certains et certaines comme une personne problématique et les gens savent pas très bien pourquoi.
Donc j'entends : « Ouais, c'est quand même pas facile de bosser avec elle. » T'es là, bah, tu ris ou quoi ? 'Fin, j'suis hyper choupinou, moi, au boulot.
'Fin, j'ai jamais fait chier personne. Et donc ça a des vrais effets dans ma vie professionnelle et le fait de quitter les réseaux sociaux, Marie disait : « Quel formidable terrain d'observation politique. »
Ben oui. Et en fait, quand tu quittes Twitter, là, moi, je devais avoir une collaboration avec un média que je viens d'annuler, entre autres parce que je devais me nourrir politiquement sur les réseaux sociaux.
Le fait de ne plus y être, j'apprends tout quatre, cinq heures après les gens, je sais absolument plus ce qui se passe.
Ben voilà, j'ai annulé parce que j'ai plus accès et j'ai plus envie d'avoir accès parce que je trouve c'est dégueulasse.
Twitter, c'est un égout qui charrie que de l'horreur. Et ben voilà, j'ai plus mon terrain de recherche, j'ai plus cet endroit pour me nourrir et m'informer.
Et donc voilà, j'ai annulé cette collaboration. Donc ça a des effets vraiment très concrets dans nos vies professionnelles, à Marie et moi, le fait de devoir quitter les réseaux sociaux.
Et quand je dis devoir quitter, c'est qu'à un moment, j'ai pris la décision de partir, mais on me l'a quand même vachement suggéré pendant des années.
'Fin, c'était devenu-- j'en pouvais plus quoi, c'était fatigant, j'en pouvais plus de ces gens. Et de mois en mois, ça devenait de pire en pire.
Donc j'ai vraiment été poussée vers la sortie. Et en fait, oui, ça a une application dans mon boulot aujourd'hui.
'Fin, je peux plus le faire de la même manière. Je peux plus faire exactement le même boulot aujourd'hui.
Oui, et juste pour rebondir là-dessus, moi, évidemment que c'est pareil aussi, que ça a d'énormes conséquences hein. Parce que moi, en plus, 'fin depuis des années,
les réseaux sociaux, c'est ma matière pour mon travail, c'est la matière pour mes bouquins, etc.
Donc en fait, on me prive, comme tu le dis hein, on me prive de mon lieu d'accès, de mon lieu d'observation. 'Fin vraiment, j'ai écrit des bouquins sur ça, moi, je travaille sur le complotisme et la construction du récit.
Donc, en fait, c'est une évidence pour moi d'être sur les réseaux sociaux. Normalement, c'est mon lieu d'action privilégié.
Et vraiment, ça, je pense qu'il y a beaucoup de gens qui ne le comprennent pas. C'est que pour moi, bien sûr, je m'y exprime beaucoup, etc.
Mais c'est surtout un lieu de travail quoi. J'y passe énormément de temps. Pourquoi ? Parce que je passe ma journée à faire des screens.
Pas des screens d'insultes, non, des screens pour étudier les tendances, les obsessions des gens, la sémantique, etc.
Parce que c'est mon taf. Et en fait, non seulement, donc là, je,
je fais le choix, mais en fait un choix que je subis de partir, parce qu'à un moment donné, très clairement, je pense d'abord à ma santé mentale, physique et à mon bonheur et tout ça.
Et donc, très clairement, ça passe avant mon taf. Et puis, par ailleurs, c'est que ça devient quelque chose d'extrêmement menaçant en fait pour moi.
C'est-à-dire que, ça, peut-être que c'est un peu différent de Florence par rapport aux questions sur lesquelles je travaille, c'est que moi, j'ai eu des,
j'ai eu plusieurs fois des menaces concrètes de l'extrême droite qui ont fait que plusieurs fois, j'ai pas pu faire de conférences, etc.
Parce qu'il y avait un vrai danger physique pour ma personne. C'est-à-dire que ça devient vraiment des lieux qui me mettent en danger concrètement.
Les antimasques, ces derniers jours, ils ont contacté mon école.
Et à un moment donné, moi, j'ai vraiment peur. 'Fin, je ne me prends pas pour une héroïne des temps modernes et je veux surtout pas l'être, mais j'ai peur que ça tourne mal quoi.
J'ai peur qu'à un moment donné, ces gens, dans les mouvances d'extrême droite, y a des gens qui font des passages à l'acte violents quoi.
Je pense qu'on a bien établi le fait qu'y a une forme d'oppression systémique concernant les femmes et en particulier concernant celles qui osent avoir un discours qui va,
qui va à contrepoil, voilà, de l'establishment, pour résumer ça comme ça.
Mais même pas en fait. Pardon. Non, non, parce qu'on n'a pas spécialement, en tout cas Marie et moi, des discours qui vont, des discours très tranchés ou qui vont à rebrousse-poil ou enfin, en fait, on fait-
On n'est pas des anti-système quoi, je veux dire.
On fait notre taf, on s'exprime sur des questions soit qui nous meuvent, comme des questions de féminisme, ou alors sur nos sujets de recherche, sur des sujets sur lesquels on s'y connaît.
En fait, c'est le fait qu'on soit des femmes qui s'expriment dans des sphères où certains hommes, parce que c'est évidemment pas tous les hommes, hein.
Zut, je l'ai fait à la bouche. J'avais toujours juré de jamais dire : « Pas tous les hommes ». C'est-- où certains hommes ont décidé que c'était des lieux masculins où on n'avait pas à foutre les pieds.
Et c'est ça qui déclenche la haine. Finalement, le contenu de nos messages n'a que très peu d'importance parce que c'est jamais...
'Fin, moi, personne ne m'a... 'Fin, on a dit : « Oui, sa carte blanche, c'est de la merde », mais personne n'a vraiment décortiqué cette carte blanche et soulevé des points précis.
Et c'est la même chose pour Marie. Je veux dire, on se fait insulter sur notre physique, on se fait insulter sur notre prétendue proximité avec l'islam, sur notre stupidité, on est les idiotes utiles.
C'est en fait de la logique de discrédit. Moi aussi hein, c'est pareil. Honnêtement, et je le dis sans aussi, 'fin,
sans orgueil, mais de manière très claire, je pense que mon taf est assez inattaquable quoi, parce que simplement parce que j'ai tellement bossé ces dernières années que j'ai fait un taf sérieux, tout simplement,
et que je veux tout à fait bien qu'on me contredise sur mon travail, mais en l'occurrence, comme tu dis Florence, ça ne se passe quasiment jamais.
Mais non, ça ne se passe pas. Donc c'est pas notre message et la parole qu'on porte qui fait qu'on est insultées, c'est ce qu'on est fondamentalement.
Et après ça, je te jure, on arrête avec le harcèlement, on passe à la cancel culture, mais -- et c'est aussi le fait qu'on a politisé cette question.
Et là, il se passe quelque chose, je trouve qu'il s'est un petit peu passé la même chose avec MeToo, c'est-à-dire qu'au début, quand des femmes disaient
: « Pouh, j'ai été tripotée par un vilain monsieur » ou « J'ai été violée par un vilain monsieur », on disait : « Oh, ma chérie, désolée, je suis de tout cœur avec toi ».
Et puis, quand les femmes ont commencé à parler de rapports de domination, de culture du viol, de violence systémique, là, on a fait : « Waouh, waouh, waouh, waouh, waouh ».
Exactement.
Et c'est exactement la même chose avec la question du harcèlement que Marie et moi, on politise.
C'est que les bonnes victimes, d'ailleurs, je déteste utiliser ce mot victime tellement on se moque de moi en disant : « Oh, la fausse victime ».
Donc, j'utilise toujours le mot cible. Mais une bonne cible de cyberharcèlement, c'est quelqu'un qui va dire : « Aïe, j'ai un peu mal » et faire une petite blague et puis passer à autre chose.
Alors que celles qui politisent la question en disant : « Mais vous vous rendez compte quand même qu'il y a quelque chose de systémique ».
Et on a des études qui ont été faites-- la première étude que j'ai retrouvée,
c'est l'ONU en 2015. J'veux dire y a des études ultra-sérieuses qui ont été faites sur le cyberharcèlement des femmes et on a tous les chiffres pour prouver ce qu'on dit.
Mais quand on politise cette question, eh ben, en fait, on prête le flanc à du nouveau harcèlement en disant : « Business de la posture victimaire.
En fait, elle sauve une carrière qui tombait à l'eau en s'inventant du harcèlement alors qu'elle ne supporte pas la critique. »
Et alors justement, ils comprennent pas non plus que ce harcèlement qu'on subit, c'est pas un choix quoi.
Donc en fait, on n'a pas le choix, on a une situation subie et donc on décide-- en plus, on a l'outrecuidance de décider d'en faire quelque chose politiquement.
Alors là, c'est quand même insupportable quoi. On est vraiment : « Mais pour qui on se prend ? » On nous dit tout le temps qu'on a le melon d'ailleurs, à cause de ça.
Oui, oui, oui, on s'est pris le melon. On est tellement fiers d'être harcelées. J'ai lu un truc récemment, c'est tellement drôle.
Enfin, c'est tellement bête que c'en est drôle. C'est que Myriam Leroy et moi, on provoquerait de manière artificielle la polémique sur les réseaux sociaux pour nourrir notre futur documentaire de capture d'écran d'insultes.
Mec, on en a assez hein, on n'a pas besoin d'en créer d'autres.
Cette phrase-là qui est quand même donc, qui révèle un certain conspirationnisme, une certaine construction de récit quoi-
Oui, ça vient d'un confrère en plus hein, c'est pas un débile sous pseudo hein, c'est un confrère, c'est un journaliste.
Voilà, ça rejoint ce que tu disais tout à l'heure sur le fait que ce ne sont pas des vieux trolls cachés. Ce sont des vraies personnes, des confrères, des gens-
Des collègues, des confrères
...des gens autour de toi. Mais donc ce qui est intéressant, c'est le fait que cette déclaration, cette accusation comme quoi tu fais enfler les polémiques pour ton futur documentaire, ces gens y croient, mais dur comme fer.
Ces gens sont persuadés que,
Il est évident que tu as des accointances et que tu fais partie du Parti écolo. Il est évident que-
Oui, oui, ça aussi, oui, bien sûr
...tu, voilà, enfin bref, plein de choses qui sont considérées comme, enfin considérées dans ce que j'appellerais ces bulles idéologiques-là, comme étant absolument factuelles et inquestionnables.
Marie, cette construction de récit, et en particulier construction de récit conspirationniste, c'est quelque chose qu'on observe beaucoup, en particulier depuis l'avènement des réseaux sociaux.
Comment expliquer le succès de ce genre de logique de, bah évidemment que Florence Hainaut, elle a...
Quelle était l'accusation encore ? Oui, elle fait enfler toutes ces polémiques pour son futur documentaire, tout ça.
Comment est-ce qu'on explique le succès de cette logique-
Mais ça, c'est de la misogynie hein. Ça, il faut être clair, c'est simplement de la basse misogynie, en fait hein.
Dans mes bras. Dans mes bras, grande folle.
Et en fait, ce qui se passe, je pense, actuellement, en termes de récit et en termes de climat politique, c'est qu'on a la réaction post #MeToo hein.
Ça, je pense que c'est très important de, justement, de repolitiser ça. C'est que #MeToo, en fait, c'est simplement le tout petit début, le tout petit commencement de la libération de la parole des femmes.
Toutes les femmes savent qu'en fait, on n'a encore rien dit. On a dit 1 % de ce qu'on a subi et encore. Pourquoi ? Parce qu'on est mortes de trouille.
On a tous eu un ex qui nous a violentées, etc. On a tous-- entre filles, on sait hein. Mais on a juste commencé un tout petit peu à oser dire.
Et en fait, ça fout la trouille au patriarcat quoi. Et donc, je pense vraiment que là, toute cette violence qui décuple, c'est en immense partie simplement de la réaction machiste et misogyne hein.
Mais c'est ce qu'on-- ça a été théorisé,
ça s'appelle le backlash. Et quand je me retourne, là, je suis devant mon ordinateur, quand je me retourne, je vois ma bibliothèque et le premier bouquin que je vois, c'est Backlash de Susan Faludi,
qui est un bouquin qui a théorisé comment chaque petite avancée féministe était suivie d'un immense backlash en réaction.
C'est-à-dire que tu fais deux pas en arrière,
bam, tu te prends un camion-benne dans la gueule. Et ce qui est très intéressant avec #MeToo et tous les autres mouvements qui suivent, c'est que le backlash, il est immédiat parce que c'est sur les réseaux sociaux. Donc, le,
on n'a même pas besoin d'attendre que la machine politique et médiatique se mette en branle. C'est,
on n'avait pas fini d'écrire le hashtag #MeToo qu'on nous disait déjà, commentait, que c'était le tribunal sur Internet, qu'on n'avait qu'à porter plainte et qu'on devait fermer nos gueules.
Et le backlash a été immédiat et extrêmement violent. Et il est toujours violent, il est toujours violent aujourd'hui.
Il est toujours violent, oui, parce que je pense qu'en fait, il est corrélé à la peur. Enfin, en fait,
le conspirationnisme, d'ailleurs, il vient toujours dans des moments, historiquement, dans les moments où il y a des velléités d'émancipation.
Et le conspirationnisme, il est toujours une arme des forces réactionnaires pour faire face à ces velléités d'émancipation.
C'est très très important à rappeler. Par exemple, historiquement, le conspirationnisme, dans sa forme structurée idéologiquement, ça apparaît au moment de la Révolution française et ce sont des acteurs anti-révolutionnaires qui,
pour discréditer l'élan révolutionnaire, disent qu'en fait, c'est un complot des Illuminatis de Bavière, de la franc-maçonnerie,
etc., pour s'attaquer à la monarchie et à l'Église, etc.
En fait, c'est marrant-
Les Illuminatis de Bavière.
Oui. Mais en fait, ça revient maintenant de la même manière. C'est ça qui est marrant quoi. Et donc on a ce truc-là.
Et puis, on a aussi, pour prendre un autre exemple historique assez célèbre,
le fameux document Les Protocoles des Sages de Sion, qui revient aussi d'ailleurs pas mal maintenant, qui est en fait aussi
un document qui vient de forces hostiles à l'émancipation, puisque c'est dans le cadre, là, de la prérévolution russe. Donc le,
le peuple russe qui va se retourner contre le tsar et le tsar qui flippe. Et donc, en fait, les Protocoles des Sages de Sion, c'est une commande de la police du tsar pour discréditer les forces révolutionnaires, pour faire croire qu'en fait
le projet de révolution, c'est un plan de déstabilisation mené par les Juifs en fait, hein.
Donc c'est évidemment très fort imprégné de rhétorique antisémite. Et en fait, je remets un petit peu de cadre historique comme ça parce que je pense que c'est très important de rappeler ça.
C'est que cet imaginaire du discrédit, de la défiance et du conspirationnisme, il vient toujours en soutien aux forces réactionnaires quand y a des mouvements d'émancipation.
Quand je dis émancipation, c'est vraiment au sens politique du terme. C'est-à-dire quand des gens essayent de se battre pour leur libération.
Et en fait, on est dans une période, je pense, historique, on est dans un moment historique extrêmement important, notamment pour le féminisme, pas seulement pour le féminisme, mais notamment pour le féminisme, où en fait, on a--
le patriarcat commence tout doucement, un tout petit peu à craqueler quoi.
À se sentir en danger, ouais.
Oui, à se sentir en danger. Et donc forcément, c'est logique. Enfin, c'est logique et c'est dégueulasse et c'est violent, etc.
Mais c'est logique que la réaction soit à la mesure de la peur que ça suscite. Faut se rappeler quand même que le patriarcat, c'est peut-être une des choses la plus ancrée dans nos sociétés.
C'est ce qui structure le plus nos rapports sociaux. Donc forcément, c'est vu par beaucoup d'hommes comme une menace.
Et là, je voudrais quand même dire un truc parce qu'on disait pas tous les hommes, mais moi, je dis tous les hommes et j'assume.
C'est-à-dire que je pense qu'il faut arrêter aussi avec cette idée qu'y a quelques machistes et puis y a les gentils qui nous soutiennent.
Non, je pense que c'est structurel, donc ça nous concerne tous quoi. Et
personnellement, ce qui me fait le plus de mal, par exemple, en ligne,
c'est pas les mecs qui me traitent de grosse connasse ou qui me disent que je suis moche en allant chercher des photos où je suis effectivement pas très jolie.
Ça, bon voilà, ça va, j'ai mon âge et je sais relativiser tout ça.
Non, ce sont les petits jeux de connivence, les petits jeux de solidarité masculine, les mecs qui t'apportent le soutien, un petit soutien, mais dont tu sens que c'est conditionné, etc.
C'est-à-dire tous les hommes, et je sais, donc c'est tous les hommes qui profitent de leurs privilèges. C'est-à-dire qui,
qui, même dans la pseudo-solidarité avec ce que tu vis, n'acceptent pas de voir qu'en fait, ils doivent accepter d'être questionnés dans leur posture.
Et donc là, je pense qu'il y a encore énormément de travail parce qu'en fait, y a aussi tout un faux pseudo-soutien aux féministes qui est en train de plomber notre puce féministe.
Et j'ai peut-être l'air un peu radicale en disant ça, mais c'est pas du tout un truc anti-homme quand je dis ça, mais c'est structurel.
C'est je pense qu'on doit mesurer que le combat, il concerne tout le monde quoi.
Je partage tout à fait le constat. Un type de réponse que j'observe souvent en dessous de tes tweets, c'est,
souvent un homme qui vient te dire : « Mais quand même, faut, ne te tracasse pas avec ça, n'y pense pas, n'interviens pas, ne réfléchis pas à ça.
» C'est de ça que tu parles ? Le gars qui te conseille aimablement de rester silencieuse ?
Oui, y a ça. Oh, attends, les exemples, je pourrais t'en donner 1 500. Enfin même 1 500, c'est pas assez. Oui, alors y a ça.
Y a : « Ne t'en fais pas, je suis là pour toi, je suis gentil » ou : « Ne te tracasse pas » ou : « Prends soin de toi, machin et tout ».
'Fin, genre comme si c'était le sujet quoi. Mais plus généralement, encore une fois, je pense qu'il faut être femme pour percevoir tout ça.
Ce sont des, comment dire ? Des mecs
qui, certes, ne vont jamais t'attaquer, certes, ne vont jamais t'insulter, voire même vont feindre de te soutenir,
mais dont tu perçois très bien qu'en fait, ça les arrange quand même, ce qui t'arrive, parce que ça leur permet de garder leurs privilèges.
Je vais parler sur les questions sur lesquelles je travaille, par exemple. Je travaille sur le complotisme, sur la Syrie, etc.
Je vois très bien qu'il y a toute une série de gars qui sont sympas avec moi, hein, mais qui travaillent sur les mêmes thématiques que moi.
Et quand j'échange avec eux, etc., bah forcément, le fait que je sois vraiment très, très fort harcelée, ils vont pas me dire que ça les arrange, hein, ils sont un peu plus subtils que ça.
Mais ça les peine pas beaucoup quoi. C'est-à-dire que bon, ben voilà, ils disent : « Oui, malheureux pour toi ».
La position dans laquelle ils sont de pouvoir te taper un petit peu sur le dos, te dire : « Allez, ça va aller ».
Cette position-là qui elle-même est ben plutôt privilégiée, la position du réconfort, du chevalier blanc qui vient taper sur le dos de Marie et dire : « Bah allez, ça va aller ».
C'est une position qui est plutôt confortable pour eux et qu'ils n'ont pas forcément-
Qui les mette pas en danger, qui les remette pas en question. Exactement. Et en fait, c'est ça. Alors, moi, je suis quand même quelqu'un qui suis un peu rêveuse et un peu révolutionnaire, hein.
Ça, c'est peut-être que j'en attends trop.
Oui.
Mais j'aimerais-
C'est pour ça que tu es ici.
Oui, c'est ça. Mais moi, je voudrais une remise en question beaucoup plus profonde. Et c'est vraiment un truc dont j'ai souffert dans mes épisodes de harcèlement.
Alors non pas que... 'Fin, bien évidemment, quand on est harcelé et que des gars nous apportent un soutien public, ça fait toujours plaisir.
Donc, je suis pas en train de dénigrer ça.
Mais j'avais souvent envie de leur dire quand, par exemple, des gars me soutenaient via un tweet qu'ils faisaient ou un statut Facebook ou quoi, en disant : « Mais écoute, gars, merci hein, c'est vraiment sympa » parce que
évidemment, c'est précieux quand on est attaqué d'avoir du soutien.
Mais en fait, ce que j'attendrais, c'est beaucoup plus que ça. C'est que-
Mais interviens, tu vois. Arrête de dire : « Je suis de tout cœur avec Marie ». Interviens. Enfin, être un allié, c'est pas nous apporter de la soupe en disant : « Allez, mange, ça va aller mieux ».
Être un allié, c'est quand on assiste à une agression, c'est ne pas faire semblant de rien. Parce que la vérité, quand t'es harcelé, c'est que t'es tout seul, hein.
T'es vraiment, 'fin, t'es vraiment, t'es toute seule quoi. Et-
Tu chiales bien quoi.
Ouais, c'est, 'fin, ah non, ah non, moi, ça, par contre, ça ne sort pas. Je refuse de leur donner ça quoi.
Moi, je chiale, mais c'est des larmes, là, je parle quand on est vraiment en plein dans l'épisode de harcèlement.
Quand tu ouvres ton tweet-- moi, quand j'ai eu l'épisode en janvier
et que j'ai ouvert mon Twitter le matin et que j'avais des milliers de notifications de tous les masculinistes d'extrême droite de France et de Navarre, qui me disaient à quel point j'étais moche, à quel point j'étais une pute, etc.
Oh si, si, je chiale. Ah oui, oui, là, je chiale.
Oui, je peux compre-- je sais, 'fin, parce que j'ai discuté avec une de tes copines, Marie, qui m'a dit : « Ben pour le moment, en fait, vu l'épisode de harcèlement que t'es en train de vivre », ben c'est elle qui gère ta page Facebook.
En fait, c'est tes potes et ça, c'est quelque chose de très important. Être un bon allié, c'est ça aussi. Donc c'est pas nous apporter de la soupe et nous envoyer des petits cœurs,
mais c'est aussi nous aider parfois dans le travail de récolte ou de tri
Parce qu'on n'est pas obligé de s'infliger ça à nous-mêmes, de voir tout ce qu'on reçoit. Et donc on-
Tout à fait
...c'est important de pouvoir déléguer en fait, de dire : « Écoute, est-ce que tu peux t'occuper de faire des captures d'écran ?
» Parce que là, c'est pas toujours facile en fait de faire des captures d'écran et de documenter ta propre humiliation.
Et donc voilà, être un bon allié, ça peut être ça aussi, mais sinon, c'est intervenir et pas-- moi, le nombre de types qui m'envoient des messages privés en disant : « Oh la la, j'ai vu qu'aujourd'hui, tu as vraiment été bien insultée.
» J'disais : « Oui, merci Jean-Roger. Et tu as fait quoi ? » 'Fin, tu vois ?
Oui.
Parce que merci de m'envoyer un message privé, mais j'veux dire, t'as réagi ? « Ah non, j'suis arrivé trop tard. » Ça n'a pas disparu hein, c'est toujours là.
Alors, si j'peux donner un conseil à tous les hommes, et Dieu sait que dans mon entourage, y en a déjà beaucoup qui l'ont lu, c'est de lire un bouquin d'Ivan Jablonka qui s'appelle « Les hommes justes ».
Et voilà, je pense qu'y a un avant et un après pour les hommes qui ont lu ce bouquin.
Et ça rend-- en tout cas, ça participe à les tricoter comme de bons alliés.
Marie, tu évoquais y a quelques instants le fait que la réponse à cette remise en question, voilà, du status quo, du patriarcat, c'était souvent,
voilà, une réponse conspirationniste, voilà, pour délégitimer la critique, finalement.
Oui.
Un type récurrent de réponse conspirationniste, et je le mets dans cette catégorie-là, c'est le fameux : « On ne peut plus rien dire. »
Pff, putain !
Est-ce qu'on peut s'attarder quelques instants sur ce fameux « On ne peut plus rien dire » et pourquoi est-ce qu'on en est arrivé là ?
Et voilà, et la légitimité de cette critique.
Mais on peut juste plus rien dire sans réaction. 'Fin, c'est-- mais on n'a jamais autant dit, il suffit de passer une heure sur Twitter, j'veux dire, tout est dit.
J'veux dire, les gens peuvent tout dire, même des choses illégales et sans conséquence. J'veux dire, y a du racisme, de l'antisémitisme, de la misogynie, n'importe quel chien avec un chapeau qui décide de
faire une vidéo anti-masque pour reprendre-- on peut tout dire.
Par contre, on ne peut plus dire sans réaction. Et les personnes que ça dérange, c'est les personnes qui, pendant très longtemps, ont été des producteurs de discours.
Donc avant, d'un côté, y avait les producteurs des discours et de l'autre côté, les personnes qui recevaient ce discours.
Et Internet et les réseaux sociaux ont complètement bouleversé ça. Et ceux qui « ouin-ouin, on peut plus rien dire »,
c'est ceux qui ont eu l'habitude de-- les influenceurs, ceux qui disaient le monde, qui détenaient le discours sur le monde, aujourd'hui, ils sont confrontés directement à la réaction des personnes qui composent ce monde.
C'est-à-dire que les blagues
sur les Asiatiques qui font tching, tching, tching et qui mangent du chien,
les blagues sur les gros et les blagues sur les blondes, eh ben, ça n'a jamais fait rire les Asiatiques, ça n'a jamais fait rire les gros et ça n'a jamais fait rire les blondes.
Sauf qu'avant, soit on envoyait un fax, on écrivait une lettre à la main. Aujourd'hui, y a les réseaux sociaux pour dire : « En fait, mec, c'est pas drôle.
'Fin, c'est pas drôle, c'est raciste. » Tu sais, bah, le nombre d'Asiatiques qui t'expliquent que
ils ont passé leur enfance à entendre des blagues racistes dans la cour de récréation, ben parce que le bon humour franchouillard,
n'hésitait jamais à prendre des accents africains et à mimer des Asiatiques qui bouffent du chien.
Mais c'est extrêmement dommageable pour ces personnes. Et aujourd'hui, elles ont la possibilité de le dire et de dire : « Ça me plaît pas.
En fait, ça me fait pas rire. » Et là, on dit : « Ah ! On peut plus rien dire. » En fait, si, on peut juste plus rien dire sans réaction et c'est pas la même chose.
Oui, j'pense qu'effectivement, ça fait partie de, justement, de l'expression grandissante de la voix des minorités.
C'est-à-dire qu'y a depuis une vingtaine d'années une structuration de plus en plus grande de la prise de parole publique des minorités dans la société.
Quand je dis minorités, c'est les minorités racisées, ce sont les femmes, ce sont-
Alors, la-- minorisées, parce qu'on est une majorité.
Oui, oui, mais moi, je continue à dire minorités, hein, parce qu'on est une minorité dans le sens politique, hein. Parce que c'est ça, à chaque fois, les machistes disent : « Mais non, vous êtes majoritaires.
» Mais c'est une minorité dans le sens politique.
Oui, tu m'as captée.
Non, non. C'est pas dans ce sens-là. Mais écoute, on peut tout à fait se revendiquer minorité dans le sens politique du terme, hein.
Mais on est une minorité-
C'est bien de l'expliquer, ouais
...politique, 'fin, politiquement parlant, on est traité comme une minorité.
Ça, c'est sûr.
Et donc, donc oui-
Mais qu'est-ce que tu voulais dire par structuration de la prise de parole des minorités ?
Oui, donc, mais c'est simplement que les minorités s'organisent depuis 20 ans pour défendre leurs droits, tout simplement.
Donc, on le voit par exemple avec les racisés, avec les personnes qui ont un handicap, les personnes qui sont issues d'une minorité sexuelle, etc., etc.
C'est-à-dire qu'il y a une structuration, y a une organisation, sur le plan associatif, sur le plan politique, pour revendiquer leurs droits et pour prendre la parole.
Et donc forcément, comme Florence le décrit très bien, ben forcément, ceux qui ont eu le monopole de la parole pendant des dizaines d'années, voire bien plus, évidemment, c'est confrontant pour eux.
Ça veut dire qu'ils sont attaqués dans leur position de domination. En fait, c'est simplement ça, hein. C'est un rapport de domination qui est questionné.
Mais simplement, ce que je voulais dire, parce que là, c'est un point vraiment qui me tient fort à cœur, c'est qu'y a eu aussi sur le « on ne peut plus rien dire », il faut aussi remettre un petit peu d'historique.
Désolée, je reprends ma casquette d'historienne. C'est qu'y a une instrumentalisation de la question de la liberté d'expression depuis une vingtaine d'années.
Je dis une vingtaine d'années parce que c'est beaucoup à l'entrée dans le XXIe siècle que ça a eu lieu.
C'est-à-dire que les forces d'extrême droite, on l'a vu beaucoup, par exemple, dans les mouvances autour de Dieudonné et Soral, ont beaucoup revendiqué la liberté d'expression pour pouvoir porter des messages de haine.
Et donc, y a eu une confusion
entre la liberté d'expression, qui est évidemment une valeur de démocratie, etc., 'fin fondatrice de notre démocratie,
et en même temps, le droit de pouvoir-- le pseudo droit,
qui pour moi n'en est pas un, évidemment, de pouvoir insulter, de pouvoir avoir une parole raciste, antisémite, négationniste, parce qu'il faut rappeler aussi que le négationnisme s'est réinvité
à la faveur de cette confusion-là.
Et donc, le « on ne peut plus rien dire », c'est ça, en fait. C'est aussi le fruit
d'une séquence politique où des acteurs d'extrême droite, des acteurs de propagande ont instrumentalisé les valeurs de la démocratie. Donc notamment la liberté d'expression pour en fait justifier de pouvoir,
perpétuer leur domination à travers du négationnisme, de la haine des femmes, de la haine des minorités sexuelles, de-- et cetera, et cetera.
Et donc, encore une fois, y a une telle confusion dans les concepts que même des acteurs progressistes, malheureusement aujourd'hui, s'engouffrent dans la brèche et ne sont plus au clair sur les concepts.
Par exemple, sur la différence entre démocratie et dictature, et cetera. On voit que-
Les Khmers verts, les Khmers rouges, je vais dire un peu plus
Tout le temps, c'est tout le temps qu'on nous dit ça. Et ça, c'est très clairement
des inversions rhétoriques qui ont été opérées par l'extrême droite y a déjà plusieurs années et qui maintenant se sont, j'aime pas, ça fait très pompeux ce que je vais dire, mais sont devenus mainstream en quelque sorte,
c'est-à-dire ont basculé dans l'imaginaire collectif.
Par exemple, reprocher à la démocratie les travers des dictatures, c'est quelque chose que sera allé lui donner, je prends ces exemples-là parce qu'ils sont les plus connus, font 20 ans.
Et maintenant, on voit que c'est, bah Florence le dit hein, oui, Khmers verts ou bien, moi, par exemple, maintenant, on a ce truc de la dictature volontaire. Oui,
dictature est mis à toutes les sauces quoi. Et c'est très--
moi, je suis obsédée par la sémantique, hein, mais c'est parce que
quand on n'est plus au clair sur les concepts, quand par exemple, on accuse, sur, verrons l'exemple des antimasques,
on accuse le soi-disant système d'imposer les masques pour porter atteinte à nos libertés, et cetera.
Bien on rentre en fait dans une inversion rhétorique qui fait qu'on ne sait plus qui est le dominant, qui est le dominé quoi.
Et c'est vraiment ce climat politique-là qui engendre le contexte actuel, 'fin, qui engendre ces dynamiques où on ne sait plus qui est harcelé, qui est harceleur et où en fait, les gens ne s'y retrouvent plus.
Moi, je suis très frappée par ça. C'est que par exemple, quand j'ai donné l'interview y a deux, trois semaines là, sur Matin Première sur la cancel culture, je percevais bien qu'en fait,
même des gens conscientisés ont besoin qu'on explique maintenant, mais en fait, qui est le méchant et qui est le gentil dans l'histoire ?
C'est comme s'il y avait plus de repères, comme si-- c'est pour ça que je parle beaucoup de récits, comme si on n'avait plus de récit collectif quoi.
Comme si tout le monde s'était enfermé dans sa petite bulle narrative, entre guillemets, et que plus personne ne s'y retrouve.
Et c'est, pour s'y retrouver, pour moi, il faut remettre du politique, on y revient. Et il faut remettre en perspective les rapports de domination.
De quelle domination il est question ? Et très clairement, le « on ne peut plus rien dire », bah, c'est les dominants qui n'ont pas envie que les dominés s'expriment. Point barre hein.
Du coup, je vous pose la question à 2 millions : la cancel culture, est-ce que ça existe vraiment ?
Alors, ce que recouvre
le terme, 'fin la réalité que recouvre ce terme qui est devenu soudainement à la mode il y a quelques semaines, en Belgique,
y a pas du tout une bonne définition parce que ce qu'on décrit depuis tout à l'heure, Marie et moi, de ce qui nous est arrivé, de ce qui est arrivé à des personnes, à des femmes autour de nous,
ça rentrerait totalement dans la définition de la cancel culture.
Mais c'est pas de la cancel culture, parce que la cancel culture, c'est quoi ? C'est des minorités qui veulent faire taire le débat, saccager l'universalisme et imposer leur...
Et donc si la cancel culture est censée venir de la gauche, alors les gens qui sont labellisés à gauche,
de gauche et qui subissent le type de violence que Marie et moi et tellement d'autres avons pu subir, si ça, c'est pas de la cancel culture, c'est quoi ?
Donc en fait, je trouve que ce terme c'est-
On peut aussi reprendre l'exemple que donnait Marie tout à l'heure qui est celui de
la jeune fille Menel qui est passée dans The Voice où
sont justement des groupuscules plutôt d'extrême droite qui sont allés chercher les vieux tweets, les vieux posts Facebook pour les remettre sur le devant de la scène et pour faire en sorte que-
Ils ont fait ça avec moi, mais y a des années quoi, y a des années. Je veux dire, y a des types qui cherchaient à avoir accès à mon compte Facebook pour voir ce que je disais, pour voir si je, parce que j'ai toujours
été très intéressée par les questions israélo-palestiniennes.
Je suis allée sur place, voilà, c'est des domaines dans lesquels j'ai travaillé et qui voulaient voir ce que j'avais écrit pour voir si on ne pouvait pas
l'afficher en disant que ça n'était pas compatible avec ma position de journaliste.
Des gens qui taguaient mon employeur et qui ont essayé de me faire perdre mon job. Même moi, je connais ça depuis, voilà, peut-être pas 2010, quand j'ai commencé, mais peut-être 2012, 13, 14, ça a commencé à arriver très très vite.
Aujourd'hui, faire de dénonciation publique ou de demande de compte public, une nouvelle inquisition qui empêche toute parole,
bah, en fait, je vois pas très bien à quoi ils se réfèrent parce que s'il doit y avoir une cancel culture, en tout cas, c'est certainement pas le produit de la gauche.
Et si les personnes, les minorités/minorisés qui réclament de participer au
discours, au discours médiatique, au discours sur le monde sont considérés comme des gens de gauche, alors je pense que la droite a un bon examen de conscience à faire parce que pourquoi les minorités et minorisés ne sont
pas associés à la droite et sont directement associés à la gauche.
Donc on peut déjà établir que ce terme cancel culture comme étant, voilà, qui désigne des méthodes, une façon de faire propre au mouvement progressiste pour faire disparaître certaines personnalités.
On peut déjà marquer que c'est absolument pas le propre des mouvements progressistes, ça, c'est clair. J'avais envie de prendre un exemple que j'avais trouvé très intéressant, notamment,
vis-à-vis de son traitement médiatique ici en Belgique.
C'était, je ne sais plus très bien quand c'était, mais c'était lorsque devaient être invités à l'ULB les rédacteurs de Charlie Hebdo et qu'un petit cercle féministe local avait témoigné de son-
Mh mh
...son opposition à la venue de voilà de ces personnalités à l'ULB. Et on avait vu partout dans la presse, que ce soit La Libre Belgique ou sur la RTBF ou quoi, on voyait cette idée
que les féministes de l'ULB veulent empêcher les rédacteurs de Charlie Hebdo de prendre la parole.
Ouais, ouais.
Et oui, oui, merci, merci Florence pour ce « ouais, ouais » tout à fait pertinent. Et donc, et ce qui est intéressant, c'est que,
on voyait donc ce petit groupe d'étudiants féministes qui n'avait absolument pas un pouvoir de censeur ou de, qui n'avait absolument pas le pouvoir de faire venir ou d'empêcher la venue de qui que ce soit,
mais on les mettait en avant comme étant des censeuses, comme étant des, voilà des obstacles à la liberté d'expression qui vont empêcher ces personnalités de pouvoir s'exprimer.
Et voilà.
Et finalement, la seule chose qu'elles faisaient, c'est exprimer leur opposition à la venue de ces personnes. Et c'était quand même retransmis et dépeint dans les médias comme étant
: « Le groupe féministe veut empêcher la venue de ces personnalités, va activement empêcher la venue de ces personnalités.
» Et ça a été transmis, voilà, un peu partout dans les médias. Je me souviens que Paul Magnette avait réagi en disant : « Bah, si elles veulent s'opposer à la liberté d'expression, on serre les mauves universitaires.
» Et puis, je me souviens que le lendemain, en tout petit, tout en bas de l'article, y avait un petit erratum pour dire : « Ah non, elles ne voulaient pas empêcher la venue de ces personnalités.
Elles disaient simplement que, voilà, elles voulaient marquer leur opposition. »
Mais en fait, c'est ça-
Mais c'était marqué en tout petit et ça n'a pas été repris-
Bah non
...par les autres médias. Oui, vas-y, vas-y Marie.
Oui, non, mais c'est juste parce que ton exemple est très bon hein, parce que ça illustre bien. Bon après, on peut discuter de l'opportunité de s'opposer à la venue des rédacteurs de Charlie, mais ça, c'est un autre débat.
Oui, autre question.
Ça, c'est une autre question, mais c'est simplement pour dire que sur ça, on peut être d'accord ou pas d'accord. Moi, par exemple, j'suis pas d'accord, mais ça, c'est vraiment une autre question.
Moi, j'suis d'accord.
Oui, c'est ça, mais ça fait partie du débat politique, quoi.
Oui, ouais.
Mais effectivement, ce qui est très intéressant, et c'est ça que j'essaie de dire à chaque fois qu'on m'interroge sur le sujet, c'est encore cette vision fantasmée du pouvoir des militants.
C'est-à-dire qu'en fait, l'immense majorité des gens qu'on critique ou bien à la venue desquels on s'oppose, etc., il leur arrive absolument rien.
C'est-à-dire qu'on n'a pas le pouvoir, en fait, qu'on nous prête. Et surtout, la liberté d'expression, c'est pas le devoir d'écouter tout le monde.
C'est-- je veux dire, y a vraiment une confusion là-dessus, comme si, par exemple, s'opposer à la venue de quelqu'un dans une université, pour reprendre cet exemple-là, c'était porter atteinte à sa liberté d'expression.
Bah non, on porte pas atteinte à sa liberté d'expression. On estime simplement que nous, en tant que membres de cette université, on n'est pas d'accord avec le fait d'accueillir une telle parole au sein de l'université.
Ça n'atteint en rien la liberté d'expression des personnes.
C'est la fameuse phrase en anglais : « Freedom of speech is not freedom of reach », c'est-à-dire-
Mh mh
...on peut toujours dire ce qu'on veut. C'est pas pour ça qu'on doit être diffusé ou mis sur un podium pour pouvoir le dire.
Exactement.
Donc, en l'occurrence, est-ce que-- les personnalités de chez Charlie Hebdo ont toute leur liberté d'expression, mais voilà, faut-il ou pas les inviter ?
Ça, c'est un autre débat.
Bah, en tout cas, on a la liberté de dire-
La liberté de se poser la question.
Voilà, c'est ça. Et la liberté d'expression, c'est aussi la liberté de dire qu'on n'est pas d'accord. En fait, c'est quand même très tordu hein,
parce que la liberté d'expression, c'est pas imposer une parole en disant : « Personne ne peut la critiquer.
» Ça n'a rien à voir avec la liberté d'expression. Et donc encore une fois, là, on voit qu'on est dans une confusion extrême.
Et je voulais juste aussi rajouter sur le concept de cancel culture qu'il vient aussi, il est importé du débat public américain.
Et ça, je pense que c'est important à dire parce qu'en fait, on a une réalité en Europe qui est très différente de celle des USA. Et que
ça augmente aussi la confusion autour de ce concept. C'est qu'aux États-Unis, on a un débat public qui est encore beaucoup plus clivé qu'ici, avec une démocratie qui est beaucoup moins forte qu'ici en termes institutionnels.
C'est-à-dire qu'en Belgique, par exemple, on peut critiquer tout ce qu'on veut en Belgique, mais on a quand même des relais organisationnels et institutionnels qui font qu'on peut quand même régler pas mal de choses par le consensus.
On le sait bien, on est les rois du compromis, n'est-ce pas ? Aux États-Unis, c'est beaucoup moins le cas. C'est-à-dire que
les militants sont beaucoup plus obligés d'aller au clash, en quelque sorte, pour obtenir, pour faire avancer leur lutte, parce qu'ils n'ont pas les relais institutionnels qu'on peut avoir ici en Europe.
Et donc forcément, ils utilisent un peu d'autres moyens, entre guillemets, que nous. Et donc c'est vrai qu'aux États-Unis, ça se produit, que par exemple, il y ait,
j'sais pas moi, des profs d'unif qui soient affichés pour des propos sexistes, etc.
Et qu'à un moment donné, ils perdent leur emploi. C'est des choses qui existent, mais ça existe aussi parce qu'il n'y a pas justement toutes les garanties institutionnelles qu'on peut avoir en Europe pour régler
ces conflits de manière autre que l'éviction de ces personnes ou le fait de les blacklister, entre guillemets.
Donc je pense que c'est important de rappeler ça aussi. C'est qu'en fait, on importe des concepts et des débats qui n'ont pas grand-chose à voir avec nos réalités ici en Europe.
Si je comprends bien, dans le terme cancel culture, bah, c'est un terme un petit peu fourre-tout.
Voilà, et certaines réalités locales, donc en l'occurrence, on parlait de cette venue des rédacteurs de Charlie Hebdo à l'ULB.
Voilà, et l'opposition du cercle féministe de l'ULB devient soi-disant emblématique d'une cancel culture alors que pas vraiment.
Et à côté de ça, c'est un terme qui désigne aussi une réalité politique aux États-Unis où, de par l'absence d'institutions et de par l'absence d'une justice sociale, finalement-
Oui, c'est ça
...les minorités ont dû improviser et entre autres choses, via les réseaux sociaux, ces nouvelles techniques, ces nouvelles-
Oui, c'est-
...chasses-coupeurs pour obtenir, oui.
Non, tout à fait. C'est en fait un moyen de lutte pour eux parce que les États-Unis, j'adore les États-Unis hein, mais c'est une société profondément inégalitaire, beaucoup plus que chez nous-
Mmh, tout à fait
...et beaucoup moins organisée institutionnellement, en tout cas sur ces questions-là. Et donc effectivement, certains parlent d'une radicalisation des minorités aux États-Unis.
Moi, j'pense pas qu'elles se radicalisent. Je pense simplement qu'elles doivent s'autogérer
et que donc comme elles s'autogèrent, eh ben elles essayent de trouver des moyens de défendre leurs droits et que forcément, ben,
les réseaux sociaux sont devenus un moyen pour eux de défendre leurs droits et de manière, il est vrai, assez,
on va dire assez violente, on pourrait dire ça comme ça, 'fin c'est la culture du clash, mais en même temps, c'est aussi parce qu'elles n'ont pas d'autres outils en main.
Et donc effectivement, cette question de contexte, je pense qu'elle est très importante à rappeler parce que
il y a des acteurs dans le débat public ici qui savent très bien cette différence de situation et qui jouent sur la confusion encore une fois,
pour nous accuser, nous militants, de choses qu'en fait, enfin, qui n'existent pas dans nos sociétés.
On le voit dans tous les exemples des gars qui ont été balancés, entre guillemets. Franchement, à part les cas les plus extrêmes et encore, regardons par exemple le cas de Bertrand Cantat pour prendre un cas extrême-
Mmh
...ben je suis désolée. Alors, oui, maintenant, c'est un peu compliqué pour lui de remonter sur scène, manquerait plus que ça.
Mais je veux dire, lui n'a eu aucun scrupule à réenregistrer des albums après, etc. Alors qu'il avait quand même tué une nana.
Donc là, on est quand même à un degré de gravité extrêmement haut. Donc-
Et moi, personnellement, je 'fin je ne m'en désole pas. Enfin, je ne dis pas que c'est bien, mais je ne me désole pas du fait qu'ils puissent continuer leur carrière.
Je note juste que ces accusations de : « Ah, vous démolissez des gens, vous les cancellez ».
C'est faux, c'est faux.
C'est faux. C'est totalement faux. Et donc je ne dis pas que c'est dommage qu'ils continuent leur carrière.
Je dis juste qu'en fait, voilà, factuellement, bah, c'est faux.
Oui, et là, on en revient à une question de privilège. C'est que je suis désolée de jouer sur la comparaison, mais nous, je peux vous assurer, ben nous, on n'agresse pas des hommes sexuellement, généralement.
Oh pourquoi ?
Oui, c'est ça. Disons que si on fait un truc vraiment répréhensible par la loi, je peux vous dire qu'en tant que femme, on va vraiment nous le faire payer toute notre vie.
Ne me lance pas là-dessus, Marie, parce que je suis de nouveau en train de relire des choses sur la violence des femmes.
J'ai un bouquin extraordinaire que j'ai devant le nez qui s'appelle : « Penser la violence des femmes ».
Ah oui.
Qui est génial, qui reprend toute une série d'études en sciences sociales sur la violence des femmes.
C'est extrêmement intéressant. Et je pense que tu devrais faire une émission là-dessus, Guillaume. Sans vouloir te womensplainer.
Je t'écoute.
C'est un--
c'est vraiment un sujet très très intéressant. La manière dont on traite la violence des femmes dans la justice depuis, 'fin de,
depuis des centaines d'années, la manière dont on la voit, dont on la traite médiatiquement, ce qui est censé être acceptable et inacceptable d'une femme.
Est-ce qu'on pourrait faire le constat alors que la cancel culture concernant les hommes en position de pouvoir, en position de, voilà, qui ont une grande couverture médiatique, qui sont des personnalités publiques,
ça n'existe pas vraiment, comme tu le disais, ou ça ne se constate pas vraiment.
Louis C.K. n'a pas vraiment été cancel.
Mais regardez Moix, Moix, Yann Moix.
Oui.
Pour moi, c'est l'exemple parfait quoi. Le mec, non seulement a eu des propos scandaleux sur les femmes, misogynes, etc.
et des agissements scandaleux, a eu en plus, rappelez-vous, il y a un an ou deux, quand on a retrouvé ses écrits négationnistes, antisémites, 'fin d'une violence absolument agaçante.
Le gars est sur les plateaux TV et il parle de cancel culture quoi. Là, maintenant, en 2020. Donc en fait, le gars, il est grillé de chez grillé.
Moi, j'ai été beaucoup à Paris ces dernières années. On m'a raconté, ça, je vais pas le raconter ici parce que voilà.
Les gens savent que c'est une crapule qui se comporte hyper mal avec les femmes, qui est hyper antisémite, etc. Je peux le dire parce qu'on est en Belgique, on a un peu moins de tabous, n'est-ce pas ? Et-
N'est-ce pas
...malgré ça, le mec, il continue à être sur les plateaux de TV en France, donc il est pas cancellé une seule seconde. Mais pire que ça, il parle lui-même de la cancel culture et il fustige la pseudo cancel culture.
Si ça, c'est pas une mise en abyme de cette problématique. C'est-à-dire que c'est vraiment les énormes connards, excusez-moi, je le dis, machistes, antisémites, etc.
Je peux vous dire que si ça avait été une femme arabe hein, qui avait eu des propos antisémites, alors là-
Alors ça-
Elle est morte
...là pour le coup, elle était finie quoi.
Finie de chez finie.
Elle était finie.
Là, non seulement il est toujours là, mais en plus, il se sent légitime à parler de la pseudo cancel culture. Non, mais où on est quoi ?
On est là en 2020 en fait.
Mais ouais, c'est à ça que je veux arriver, c'est qu'il y a finalement le constat que pseudo cancel culture, ça n'existe pas vraiment en ce qui concerne ces personnalités publiques, en tout cas masculines.
Mais par contre, et là, je reviens à ce que tu disais sur la situation aux États-Unis, en ce qui concerne les minorités, en ce qui concerne les mouvements militants.
J'ai notamment pu regarder une vidéo qui durait, je crois, une heure et demie d'une youtubeuse trans qui expliquait que
en défendant, par exemple, ou en l'occurrence, elle ne défendait pas un point de vue qu'on appelle transmedicaliste, c'est-à-dire qui,
ouh là, on va pas entrer là-dedans, mais-
Oui, je vois ce que tu veux dire
...qui défend une approche plutôt très biologique de la question des transidentitaires, entre guillemets.
Et donc
elle était associée à une personnalité qui a peut-être vaguement défendu une position comme ça.
Et donc, elle se retrouvait indirectement, sans
Sans que ce soit à aucun moment vrai qu'elle ait défendu ses positions, elle se retrouvait cancelled et coupable de, 'fin jugée coupable par ce tribunal numérique d'avoir défendu ses positions.
Et donc là, on est quelque part dans la Cancel Culture telle que dépeinte dans les médias, c'est-à-dire on ne pardonne pas, c'est-à-dire il y a une dualité.
C'est-à-dire si tu n'es pas en train de publiquement dénoncer cette personnalité, eh bien finalement, c'est que tu es avec elle. Euh-
Mais c'est pas la Cancel Culture, tu vois, c'est juste... En fait, moi, je bugue complètement sur ce mot parce que la fille, elle est pas cancellée.
La Cancel Culture, en fait, dit quelque chose qui n'existe pas. Est-ce qu'il existe des phénomènes où, de manière très violente, des internautes s'attaquent, remettent en cause et demandent le licenciement ?
Oui, ça arrive. Est-ce qu'il y a des gens qui en sont victimes et qui sont vraiment... Oui, y en a. Je veux dire, y a moi qui montre que oui, pas toujours hein.
Mais évidemment, on va trouver un exemple à gauche, à droite de gens qui bénéficient de moins de privilèges parce que ce sont des travailleurs et pas des personnes médiatisées.
Donc oui, ce phénomène existe, mais ce mot, c'est juste pas possible quoi. 'Fin, parce que ce mot décrit une réalité qui n'existe pas, en tout cas décrit quelque chose qui n'existe pas.
On ne cancel pas les gens. Maintenant, y a quelque chose, mais alors trouvons-lui un autre mot, une autre manière de l'appeler.
Tout à fait. Donc moi, je suis tout à fait d'accord avec ça. Il faut faire vraiment attention à cette dénomination parce qu'elle désigne une réalité qui n'existe pas.
Et puis alors, y a deux choses. Y a d'abord, il faut remettre en perspective, encore une fois, les rapports de domination.
En fait, effectivement, les personnes en position de domination et de privilège ne subissent pas cette pseudo Cancel Culture.
Par contre, effectivement, des personnes qui sont plus en situation de domination, quelle qu'elle soit, vont en subir plus les conséquences, comme disait Florence,
sur le plan du travail ou bien sur tous les plans, si on est d'une minorité ethnique ou culturelle,
si on est défavorisé économiquement, etc.
Bien évidemment que la parole publique qu'on va pouvoir avoir à notre égard va avoir des conséquences plus grandes sur notre vie que si on a une visibilité publique.
C'est d'ailleurs l'occasion de faire une petite parenthèse. Moi, j'estime que je suis privilégiée hein, et j'estime que ma visibilité publique, elle me protège.
Donc il faut pas demander ce que doivent subir des gens qui n'ont aucune visibilité publique. Donc, il faut remettre en perspective les rapports de domination.
Par ailleurs, je pense que c'est important de dire par rapport au cas que tu décris, le cas de cette militante,
c'est qu'effectivement, nous sommes dans une phase, et là, c'est pas inutile de remettre un petit peu d'historicité, encore une fois.
On est dans une phase de revendication des minorités qui passe par certains moyens assez radicaux et que je pense que c'est une phase historique nécessaire.
C'est-à-dire que justement, on a des minorités qui ont vécu un rapport de domination tellement fort pendant tellement longtemps qu'on est pour le moment dans une espèce de transition où ils doivent inverser un petit peu le rapport de domination.
Et que, hélas, dans toutes les luttes sociales, et je dis pas que c'est bien hein, mais ça fait des dégâts collatéraux.
Et je pense qu'on ne doit pas les nier, ces dégâts collatéraux. Je le vois beaucoup dans les milieux militants. Pour le moment, y a des choses très très moches qui se passent dans les milieux militants
à cause de désaccords très profonds sur ces questions-là, notamment sur la transidentité, etc.
Et on assiste à des choses très moches. Non, mais Florence, tu dois sûrement le voir aussi dans les milieux féministes, etc.
On a véritablement des gens qui se,
qui se déchirent et c'est sale. Ça passe par des choses très sales, honnêtement.
Parfois, quand je vois des féministes, même avec lesquelles je suis en total désaccord, mais se faire lyncher en ligne par d'autres féministes, je me dis : « C'est moche.
On peut pas trouver ça beau. » Même si je-
C'est le,
le phénomène qu'on appelle
dog pile, c'est-à-dire une personnalité dit quelque chose de problématique et puis une autre, en l'occurrence une autre féministe, va lui répondre peut-être de manière assez agressive, et puis une autre, et puis une autre, et puis une autre.
Et puis la personne qui a pris la parole publiquement se retrouve avec, ben des centaines, des milliers de tweets, de commentaires agressifs et ça peut avoir un grand poids, en termes de santé mentale.
Mais c'est ça. Par exemple, je vais prendre un exemple très concret. Quelqu'un avec qui je suis en désaccord politique total,
la, euh, Marguerite Stern, celle qui a lancé les collages contre les féminicides en France.
Donc, c'est une militante féministe, mais qui par ailleurs est transphobe, qui a un problème sur la question de la transidentité, qui est plus qu'un problème, c'est...
voilà. Mais qu'est-ce qui se passe ? C'est que du coup, elle est attaquée pour ses positions. Et ça, c'est normal hein, c'est le débat public hein.
Mais on assiste à
des espèces de pugilats dans les sphères féministes qui,
dont on ne peut pas se réjouir. C'est-à-dire quand moi, quand je vois des centaines de femmes attaquer une féministe, je peux pas me réjouir pour la cause féministe, même si je suis d'accord avec ces femmes qui attaquent cette féministe.
Je peux pas me réjouir que ça se passe parce que je pense que ça montre à quel point on est dans un contexte politique extrêmement glauque quoi.
'Fin, vraiment, on est dans un contexte politique très difficile. C'est triste de voir des gens qui devraient être solidaires se déchirer entre eux.
Et je suis la première à le faire hein. Pour moi, c'est normal qu'on ait des débats au sein de notre camp. Mais là où ça devient un petit peu triste,
c'est quand ça tourne à l'insulte, au harcèlement, finalement.
Bien sûr. Mais donc tu nuances cette violence dont on peut être témoin donc dans le camp progressiste, dans le camp militant.
Tu nuances en disant : « C'est une phase de transition. »
Mais donc oui, je pense que c'est une phase de transition et qu'elle est nécessaire. Elle est douloureuse, elle fait des dégâts collatéraux.
Et les dégâts collatéraux, ils vont être chez qui ? Pas chez les hommes qui sont à la télévision et qui sont en puissance, etc., 'fin qui ont une visibilité publique hein.
Chez les militants de base, chez les femmes, chez les racisés, etc. Y a des dégâts collatéraux, mais je pense que c'est une phase par laquelle on doit passer pour arriver à,
quelque part, à bousculer certains rapports de domination. Donc-
On n'a jamais fait une révolution en disant : « S'il vous plaît ». C'est ça. Enfin, alors voilà, les dégâts collatéraux, rien que le fait de mettre le mot « dégât » dessus, c'est un dégât, ça ne devrait pas se passer.
Mais pour aujourd'hui, je ne vois pas comment faire pour avancer et revendiquer, et revendiquer de l'espace et revendiquer le droit, le droit à la parole et le droit d'être reconnu, le droit d'être entendu.
Je ne vois pas comment le faire. Si on veut pas du tout de dégâts collatéraux, alors on ferme nos gueules. C'est ça.
Exact. On dit rien, en fait. Exactement.
Et donc ces événements-là, ces mouvements-là de, voilà, de violence comme le décrivait Marie, vus de l'extérieur par, on va dire, oui, les hommes qui n'ont pas besoin de,
de défendre un point de vue politique.
De l'extérieur, y a cette peur de l'attaque sur la liberté d'expression comme on l'a,
comme on l'a, voilà, développée tout à l'heure, et qui amène donc à ce « on ne peut plus rien dire », oui, au fait qu'on emploie des mots comme cancel culture.
Est-ce que vous êtes d'accord avec ce résumé-là ?
Bah, je pense que ce qu'ils disent, outre le fait qu'ils disent « ouin ouin », mais ça, tu l'auras bien compris, c'est : « Ah, c'est pas confortable ».
Eh ben ouais, c'est pas confortable. C'est ça. Pas de bol. 'Fin, tu vois, nous non plus, c'est pas confortable. Et désolée, voilà, désolée de mettre des cailloux sous tes fesses, t'es moins confortablement assis sur ta chaise.
Mais oui, je comprends que ce soit difficile pour eux et je comprends tout à fait. Comprendre, ça veut pas dire que je trouve que c'est acceptable,
mais je comprends tout à fait les logiques qui les poussent à devenir violents, à devenir insultants.
Moi, on viendrait me dire : « Oh, by the way, tu vois tes privilèges ? » Eh ben, je veux dire, à un moment, il va falloir un petit peu partager, voilà, va falloir un petit peu partager le gâteau.
Ben, je suis pas sûre que je serais méga contente. Mais je, voilà, j'essaie de le faire, j'essaie d'utiliser intelligemment mes privilèges.
C'est ce que j'ai fait avec cette carte blanche sur le foulard, qui était très bien soit dit en passant, je ne la regrette pas.
Oui, qui n'avait rien d'excessif, quoi. Mais surtout que non, elle n'avait rien d'excessif.
Ouais.
J'ai-- là, c'était de l'utilisation intelligente de mes privilèges parce que je savais que les filles qui portent le foulard avaient essayé de faire publier une carte blanche et que personne ne l'avait prise dans la presse.
Et je me suis dit : « Bah, voilà, 'fin,
utiliser intelligemment mes privilèges, c'est me dire : ben voilà, je vais profiter du fait que je suis journaliste, que je suis, et que je vais pouvoir plus facilement, 'fin, diffuser ma carte blanche.
» Bon, je l'ai payée cher, mais je me demande si ça n'valait pas le coup, finalement.
Bon, je crois qu'on arrive tout doucement au bout de ce podcast. On a bien dépassé les timings qu'on avait imaginés au départ.
Mais donc, en résumé, la cancel culture, en ce qui concerne les, voilà, les hommes bien installés, privilégiés, en particulier les hommes, voilà, qui ont une,
qui ont une position de pouvoir, qui ont une grande couverture médiatique, n'existe pas vraiment.
Ces personnes n'ont jamais vraiment été cancelled. En revanche, il y a donc, et Florence, tu disais que tu ne voulais pas appeler ça de la cancel culture, mais il y a, au sein des mouvements militants, au sein des minorités,
des dérives plutôt, voilà, plutôt violentes, plutôt choquantes-
Mh mh
...mais que Marie nous expliquait que c'était tout à fait normal d'un point de vue historique et que c'était simplement une phase de transition.
Enfin, je le dis avec beaucoup d'espoir.
Est-ce que vous êtes d'accord avec ce résumé ? Oui, tu le dis avec beaucoup d'espoir, on croise les doigts.
Parce que je suis pas voyante, hein, mais j-
Ouais, ouais, c'est ça.
...je trouve quand même qu'en termes historiques, ce serait cohérent, quoi. C'est, voilà, qu'on passe par une phase assez radicale, mais nécessaire pour abolir certains rapports de domination.
Très bien. Quelque chose à rajouter avant de se quitter ?
Ouais, t'es très fort en résumé, Guillaume. J'aime bien.
Oui, je suis quelqu'un de très-
C'est un plaisir avec toi.
...très carré.
Alors, je suis désolée, je pense que tu voulais pas du tout faire ton podcast sur les questions, euh-- en tout cas, tu ne voyais pas ton podcast tel qu'il s'est passé.
On a parlé beaucoup plus de harcèlement et beaucoup plus de féminisme et, euh-
Mais ça me paraît tout à fait pertinent.
Et merci de nous, d'avoir changé ton programme et d'avoir tant travaillé pour nous poser des questions que tu n'auras pas eu l'occasion de nous poser parce qu'on a complètement dévié.
Donc moi, je te remercie.
Sois rassurée, j'ai pu poser les questions principales qui m'intéressaient.
Bah parce qu'après, vous me laissez parler. T'as vu, Marie ? Oui, oui.
Est-ce que vous voulez rajouter quelque chose vis-à-vis de tout ce qu'on a pu développer aujourd'hui ?
Euh, oui, moi, je voudrais quand même que dans les insultes qui vont affluer quand tu posteras- ...quand tu vas poster le podcast, je voudrais lire des nouvelles choses parce que je trouve que c'est fort déjà vu.
D'accord.
Voilà, ayez un peu d'imagination, merci.
Très bien. Bien, dans ce cas, on va se quitter sur ça, sur ce magnifique conseil. Je vous dis à dans deux semaines pour un prochain épisode. Au revoir.
À bientôt. À bientôt.
Voilà, c'est déjà la fin de cet échange avec Marie Peltier et Florence Hainaut, que je remercie chaleureusement pour avoir accepté l'invitation.
De formidables invités dans les semaines qui viennent. Comme je l'expliquais à Florence, je vais entre autres bientôt avoir la chance de recevoir la très distinguée Rokhaya Diallo,
qui est militante antiraciste et autrice de nombreux livres à ce sujet.
Pour ne pas manquer les prochains épisodes, n'oubliez pas de vous abonner au podcast via votre application de podcast préférée.
Et si c'est la première fois que vous écoutez Septante Minutes Avec, bah déjà, bienvenue.
Et ensuite, je ne peux que vous encourager à aller explorer les anciens épisodes avec
un formidable assortiment d'invités, tous plus intéressants les uns que les autres, que ce soit le CEO de Google Belgique, des journalistes comme Alain Gerlache et Hugues Dayez,
des universitaires comme Julie Daché, Philippe Van Parijs ou Olivier Klein.
Et il y a même une interview avec Myriam Leroy où on parlait de... Ah ben, on parlait de cyberharcèlement, de journalisme et de féminisme.
Je vous souhaite une bonne écoute et je vous dis à dans deux semaines. Prenez soin de vous.